Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just checking in on you mother fuckers.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
It is three 48 in the morning.
I'm a little jet lagged here,
knocking out the podcast.
I just did a two shows on a,
what would be at Tuesday and Wednesday here in Liverpool.
And um,
at the Liverpool Phil Harmonic,
they had a little drum kit back there.
I didn't have any earplugs.
I ended up realize that they were going to give me one,
so messed around on it a little bit,
but the fucking crowds were amazing.
All of my jokes seem to be working on this side of the pond.
There were a couple of things that I had to make minor adjustments to.
MMM.
What are the lines people don't get,
but I'm leaving it in the fucking special anyways.
I don't give a shit,
but this thing's ready to go.
I am very excited,
very relaxed.
I'm in a great place and um,
I want to thank everybody who came out on a school night,
Tuesday and Wednesday.
I could not have had a better time.
And thank you to,
uh,
create scans who opened up for me.
Um,
I had a great time working with him.
He fucking killed both shows.
Um,
which I always like.
I hate doing a show where,
you know,
I like it wire to wire,
everybody does a good job.
So there's none of that bathroom break bullshit.
Um,
while people are on stage,
you know,
so underrated Liverpool,
beautiful Goddamn city also helped that the weather was perfect.
Um,
I guess,
you know,
she usually gloomy and rainy around these parts,
but uh,
we got to sunny days and tonight Liverpool had a game and people still came out
to my show,
which was very flattering.
And uh,
I kinda got all back into the whole premier league shit as a Liverpool one.
So I guess you get three points for winning.
And last I checked,
they were like one point ahead of man's city.
All right.
Now this is what's interesting.
Liverpool is backed by American dollars.
All right?
Man City is backed by Saudi and Saudi Arabian money.
Yeah.
Now we buy oil from Saudi Arabia.
So in a lot of a bunch of it.
So in a lot of ways they're also in around about way back
by American dollars.
But for what I heard,
rumor has it is we got more oil in our country at this point than they do.
So I don't know how to do this fucking math.
All I know is the owner of the Red Sox owns uh,
Liverpool.
And you didn't realize how fucking insane it would be if the owner of the red
sox owned him right through the curse of the babe ended that curse.
And from what I heard,
Liverpool is never won that Premiere Championship.
There's 10 fucking games left.
So all they gotta do is keep winning.
There's no playoffs,
which play offs,
which blows my mind because they're leaving so much money on the table.
Like who am I as an employer?
My thing,
who am I as an American?
This is what Americans do.
It's what fucking English people do.
You barge in and you fucking put your own ideas as somebody else's foreign land.
So why not?
You guys got to have a play off.
This is like college football all over again.
Everybody would pitch at the end of the fucking year.
It's a little bit different.
That's actually,
it's a lot different.
It actually kind of makes sense,
but I don't know.
Call me a stupid American,
but they had a fucking play off.
Like what if you know you,
if you play all fucking year and and you lose by one point so you don't get the
championship,
you're one point less.
Let's say it ended today in Liverpool Beats Man City by one point.
What if they just fucking had one more game?
The top two teams or what if they had a special thing that if the top two teams,
if you're within five fucking points,
if you're in second place by five points of or less,
you've earned a playoff game and they play a one game winner takes fucking all.
All right.
You're going to tell me like how many fucking people are going to tune in for
that,
you know?
Instead of having all these fucking games going on at the same time.
Hey Bill,
you know,
I don't know if you've noticed,
but the league's pretty functionally successful.
We really don't need your fucking ideas.
I Dunno.
Sorry,
I just grew up with playoffs.
Playoffs.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
that's fucking was pretty exciting and the next time I really got into it,
you know,
everybody was walking around today with this scarves on and saw this guy with a
suit on.
He was going to work,
but he's still at a white shirt on with a red tie.
Clearly s like supporting his team.
Like people were fucking into it.
It killed me.
It killed me to not go to that game.
Obviously I did had a great time doing the show,
but like,
just to know that that was right there.
Most Sal is playing in these fucking like the Wayne Gretzky of soccer right now
and I'd have a chance to see another great athlete live.
Uh,
next time I come back I'm going to be drinking.
I figure I'll do a one off show here the day before the day after.
Probably the day after.
It'd be better if there was a game right now.
Wait,
do the show first and then,
then I do the game,
then I get all banged up and I go to the fucking game and I'll put a bunch of
money on Liverpool.
That way I'll give a fuck.
Um,
I still don't understand why the defense is allowed to stop fucking running.
And then you're off sides.
If that's the case,
why don't you just put four fat lady's back on defense that can't fucking run.
Yeah.
And then they'd never get near your net.
Right.
Just have them sitting down in the grass playing with the fucking daisies.
I don't get it.
Whatever.
Somebody will explain it to me.
Um,
so,
uh,
I got to tell you about a,
a little medical episode that I had.
So I flew over here from New York City.
Uh,
I don't remember if I,
I was so fucked up.
I don't remember if I even told you this.
Did I?
I did I already tell the story about almost faint.
Well,
I figured out why I almost fainted in the elevator.
Right.
I already told you this stuff's right.
I told it on Monday.
Recap real quickly is I,
the day after I flew from New York to La,
I mean to,
uh,
to Manchester took the train over to Liverpool.
Um,
they had a fucking steam.
Yeah.
And they had a sauna and I went to the sauna and I was in there and I wasn't
sweating.
I'm just like,
it didn't feel hot.
I'm like,
what the eff,
this fucking thing sucks.
And then I went to the steam and I was like,
all right,
this is better.
And then when I left,
I had to walk up a flight of stairs.
When I got to the elevator,
like,
dude,
I almost went down like the closest I've come to fainting
ever,
other than from alcohol,
just doing the fucking face plant.
So
I was blaming their sauna,
thinking it was that shit that heats you up from the inside.
And I didn't realize how fucking hot I was,
but,
uh,
when I told a few people what happened,
um,
it was,
I was dehydrated from the f I don't think I drank enough water when I was in New
York.
So I was already a little dehydrated.
Then I got on a seven hour fuck six and a half,
seven hour flight,
and then didn't drink water and then took a sauna and a fucking steam.
So,
and then all my symptoms,
like I fucking,
when I went into the locker room,
I was by myself and all of a sudden I was like,
oh my God,
I got to fucking sit down.
And then I was like dry heaving.
And I was like,
oh my God,
what the fuck I'm going to Puke.
And then I didn't puke and there was nobody in the locker room.
And then
after that,
then all of a sudden it wanted to come out the other end,
not to get fucking gross,
but,
uh,
it did.
And I think that toilet is retired and somebody told me,
said,
all of these are signs of you are dehydrated,
your dehydrated.
I saw I was dehydrated before I took a fucking sauna and a steam and my dumb ass
almost fucking passed out.
Did I tell you this story?
I can't remember.
No wait,
I didn't.
That's right because I had to show that night and when I did the show there was
a couple of,
when I,
I ramped up the energy and I was like touching my toes,
doing something.
I came back up fast.
I was like,
Oh fuck am I going to pass out right here on stage?
Um,
dude,
I got on the fucking elevator
and this other guy going on with me and I was just leaning
on the fucking like armrest there that the rail and I was just staring at the
ground.
And you know that deal when you think you're going to faint and you just trying
to keep yourself cool and every time you think you hit the top like,
okay,
I could deal with this.
I can maintain my consciousness.
It goes a little higher and you let go fuck off.
Fuck,
hang in there.
And I can't remember if the dude was talking to me or not.
I think he said something to people.
And I got off,
I got off at the wrong floor,
so I had to walk down a flight of stairs and I got to the first set of first
step and just sat down.
And then the guy looked at me,
he goes,
are you okay?
All right.
Now if I was a woman,
I would be like,
no,
I need help.
I have a family and a child that's depending on me to not die.
Right?
But I'm a man.
So of course I said,
yeah,
I'm fine.
Yeah,
dude,
I was,
I was not fine.
Yeah.
And He,
you know,
he's a guy.
So he's like,
alright,
well this is emotionally weird to deal with this with another guy.
And he just fucking left.
So I sat on the fucking stairs for like,
I dunno,
like another like minute.
And I slowly walked down the stairs and I just,
uh,
I,
I've made it into the,
the hotel room.
And at that point I,
uh,
I asked club soda.
Kenny,
I just texted him,
said,
bring me a Gatorade and some fucking waters and shit.
So I just pounded that and I was all right,
but Jesus Christ or freckles almost went down all freckle.
Okay,
here's one for you.
If you're a fucking dumb ass like me,
and you get on a plane and fly for six hours more or more and you're already
dehydrated yet,
don't go take a fucking sauna.
And then two,
I took two steams cause I was like that Saunas not doing shit.
And then when I went into the steam room,
I thought I was sweating.
It was just the fucking steam.
And then I went back in again,
fucking idiot.
Um,
but other than that,
I had a great time here.
Uh,
you know,
checked out the Beatles statue.
I did a couple of like touristy things,
but other than that I just tried to walk around and look at a lot of beautiful
buildings and everything.
Really,
really great city.
And the people were cool as shit.
And uh,
I kept striking out with the food though.
Jesus Christ's eight at this fucking Italian place.
Who the fuck?
I know fucking asshole gets a Tahlia in Liverpool,
England.
I went,
I ordered these fucking,
I got some oysters cause you know,
I'm trying to keep my figure for my special.
So what are some oysters?
Okay.
And I'm thinking,
you know,
there's water right here,
these oysters gotta be fresh.
Did that taste fresh at all?
And then I got one of those,
those uh,
you know those rice balls tines make is like,
it's fucking rice.
It's almost like a result.
It's got like cheese in it and then they deep fried.
It's fucking,
that was my little,
that was my cheat meal.
Right.
So I order those things that shows up with like truffles on it.
It was the blandest.
Yeah.
I never sent back food and I just don't have the fucking
courage to do it because you guys send me in stories about sending back food in
like what happens?
Cause I'm always of the belief they're going to get mad at you and then they're
going to spit on your food.
But like these fucking things was so bad.
There was like,
there was no fixing it.
You know what I mean?
It's not like,
Oh hey,
this is medium rare.
Could you make it medium?
It's just like,
this tastes like the person who cooked it doesn't know how to cook.
Is this bringing your fucking six year old to workday and they fucking made my
rice balls here.
Okay.
And I just was like,
you know what?
I'm not fucking eat.
This is,
this is how rebellion,
this is the most rebellious I've ever been in a restaurant because I worked in
one and I never want,
I always tip well even if they fucking suck.
So I,
I ate one of them and I was just like,
I am not going to out of politeness and how my parents raised me to not waste
food,
eat these other five fucking things,
and then have to get on an elliptical and work off something that I didn't even
enjoy.
So I just set it to the fucking side and eight,
my fishy oysters and the waitress came back around and she goes,
okay.
She's like,
how was everything?
And I said,
what?
I always say great.
It was all great.
It was awesome.
And she's looking clearly seeing that I barely touched it.
She goes,
everything was fine.
And I was like,
yeah it was great.
Can I just get the check?
And that was it.
So the upside is with,
with being dehydrated
and almost puking and shitting and fucking eaten this shit food over here.
I,
I've actually drop some pounds cause laid off the booze doesn't hurt either.
Um,
so anyways isn't a thing I learned by the way.
I'm just gonna keep saying anyways cause I can't stop saying it.
I like to think it's part of my charm.
Um,
I've always wanted to go to that tt race since I found out about it about six,
seven years ago
and I keep trying to book myself on the Isle of man and they just don't have
shows there.
I don't know what the deal is.
Well they don't know who I am and they don't give a fuck.
I don't know what it is.
And I just realized today looking at the map that Liverpool is like 45 fucking
minutes flight away.
So I'm thinking of maybe at some point doing a one off show here in flying over
and seeing that race before.
You know,
people who don't race motorcycles and don't watch motorcycle racing are so
outraged by it that they shut it down.
MMM.
You know,
those are the same fucking people try to get fighting out of hockey and they
just,
they just try to ruin any sort of gladiator thing that is left in society.
You know what I mean?
Um,
oh,
the latest dead person that people have been going after.
They went after John Wayne now they just,
they went after,
I think Bill Hicks.
It's the stupidest shit ever.
All these white people trying to show how fucking progressive they are by
keeping the limelight off of them and all the mistakes they've made socially in
their lives by now there,
I think they've attacked all the white people they can get that are alive now.
They're going after dead people,
dead white people.
Apparently Davy Crockett was a piece of shit.
I just don't,
how is that helping anything,
you know,
not to mention it's an astoundingly white thing to do.
To think that you have to go back in history to find people like that.
And then it's up to you to redefine how we are perceiving these five.
Why don't you deal with what the fuck's going on now?
That's another really cringe worthy thing.
You know,
when people,
I can't believe in 2019 well that's because you're white.
I'm sorry.
It's just,
I don't,
I'm just so sick of these fucking left the whities patting themselves on the
fucking back,
you know,
with all of this shit,
acting like they're fucking doing something.
It's like,
listen,
if you want to get involved,
there's plenty of groups that you can join that go and just,
you can physically take time out of your fucking life to go do something.
Stop Fucking,
I dunno.
I'm just,
you know,
remember that guy used to do the fucking humble brags.
The guy passed away.
He was still around it.
Maybe he would do another one that had to do with humble bragging,
but like,
it's in like a social way.
Woke bragging or some shit.
I don't know what it is.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I actually miss,
I misunderstood when the,
when the,
um,
the thing for Brody was going to be,
uh,
Brody Stevens is going to be,
um,
I don't want him announcing this thing here because it's just for family and
comedians.
They're going to shut down the comedy store,
the shutting the whole fucking thing down,
not making any money that night.
This is what this guy meant to the comedy store and everybody that knew and
loved them,
this shutting down the entire fucking comedy club March 11th,
and we're going to have a big night remembering him telling stories and all
that.
It's going to be fucking unbelievable.
And I feel so thankful that I'm actually going to be in town when this goes down
and I can't wait to,
uh,
to go down there and be a part of that.
And um,
what else did I want to say about that?
I can't fucking remember him.
It's not going to have half asleep here.
Oh yeah.
I was also able to call in Brody,
you know,
obviously did a podcast,
the all things comedy network.
And I was talking to one of the people over there and they said today that over
100,
say that again.
100 people showed up,
um,
to be on his final podcast.
All went over,
drove themselves over there,
called in ice,
skyped in.
And um,
it just really goes to show you,
uh,
like I,
you know,
I don't think I've ever seen that.
You know,
unfortunately I've seen a lot of people pass away,
but like,
um,
this guy really touched a lot of people,
so you know,
if you can take a positive out of something,
so fucking sad,
that is,
uh,
that would definitely be it.
So I imagine at this point,
if I actually had the advertising,
I would read some.
So I'm just going to say,
Hey,
I'm going to the,
uh,
the advertising now and this is where we will edit it in.
All right.
And now we're back.
We're back to the podcast here.
Um,
what else is there to talk about?
I'm going to Glasgow now.
What I love about Glasgow aside from the fact that I love,
I love Scotland,
um,
is I'm a huge ACDC fan and old ACD DC fans like myself all know that the live
album,
if you want blood,
you got it was recorded in Glasgow
and I are for years would listen to that song,
the Jack
and um,
when Bond Scott Sang,
she told me she was a virgin.
He would say something.
I couldn't,
I any virgins,
whatever.
I could never understood.
Stand what he was saying.
He was actually saying any virgins in Glasgow,
Glasgow,
I believe that's what he's saying.
And I never,
when I finally went,
I thought it was Glasgow,
so I wasn't saying it right then it went there and I heard how they said at
Glasgow,
all of a sudden it just clicked in my head going,
wait a minute,
is this where they fucking recorded that?
So of course I had to figure out where the theater was that they recorded it and
I'm like,
I got to fucking play there.
I've got to tell my shit jokes where the greatest rock band,
as far as I'm concerned,
rock and roll band ever performed one of the greatest rock alive rock albums
ever.
And unfortunately I looked it up and it was,
uh,
it no longer exists.
Um,
speaking of which,
when you come in and to Liverpool,
they have,
uh,
the club where the Beatles played like 200 shows,
like some of their first 200 shows.
And now that I am an experienced tourists,
I said to the driver,
I said,
now is this the original place?
Is this the exact place?
Because I remember when I was in London,
everybody,
this is a stupid Abbey road thing where you're walking across the street.
I want to be John.
I want to be Paul.
That's not the same crosswalk crosswalk has been moved.
So you're not standing where they stood.
Okay.
So I asked and I'm like,
okay,
now the,
that fucking crosswalk bullshit,
I did that.
And it turned out that they fucking,
you know,
that wasn't where they were.
Now was this club really the place where John Paul Ringo and George all played
their first 200 shows,
the cavern club or something like that?
And the guy goes,
he's like,
yeah,
no,
it isn't a
place where they originally played.
It's like a fucking hotel now,
but this is close.
It's on the street.
So the best thing you can do is you can walk down the street where they walked
to go to a club that no longer exists.
But when you go into the club that they say is the club,
it's not the fucking club.
Oh,
did I take a picture?
I gotta I gotta um,
I don't want to fucking hurt anybody's business here,
but I was with,
uh,
Andrew thumbless.
He sees like shooting stuff for my patrion page on this tour.
And we getting ready for my special.
And,
uh,
we went to go,
you know,
he's a huge Beatles fan.
So we went down there and we would checking out,
uh,
all of these,
come on.
Did I take a picture of it?
Fuck,
I didn't take a picture.
God dammit.
We went to this,
this Beatles Museum.
Okay.
Now if you're trying to attract people,
you'd,
it's if you have artifacts from the Beatles,
which you want to do is have like a couple of yet yet,
not yet.
Your best ones.
You want to keep your best ones in there also,
it's a let down,
but you got to put something from your top five out front.
So we go to walk into this fucking museum.
He goes,
I want to go in,
and I was like,
all right,
all right.
And he goes,
you don't want to go?
And I go listen to it.
You're fucking huge Beatle fans.
I want to ruin this for you.
Let's fucking go in.
So we go to walk up the steps to go in and I swear to God they have this
mannequin that they dressed like John Lennon and it was just a mannequin and it
had the all white suit that he had and it wasn't the white suit,
it was just a white suit and they glued or taped a beard to a mannequin's face
and put this awful fucking wig on it.
It looked like me when I dress up to do the comedy jam and I just started
laughing and I was just like,
Andrew,
I go look at this fucking thing.
If this is what they have to get you in there,
what the fuck do they have in there?
And he just started laughing and we were just like,
all right,
fuck it,
let's get out of here.
So I think,
I think we made the right move on that one.
Um,
but they did have a lot of cool stuff and we went to another place that,
a bunch of cool t shirts and shit.
I tried to find something for my daughter.
I actually couldn't find anything but uh,
I got to get her something.
But,
um,
I am excited in a couple of days cause I'm,
I'm flying out,
you know,
my family over here and I can't wait.
MMM.
To see my Kiddo,
I signed up for Skype and that's been a good thing.
So I talked to her like three times a day
and uh,
yeah,
she's Hilarious,
but it's just killing me.
This stuff I'm missing.
Like this morning,
my wife was putting socks on her and they had a little teddy bear on it and she
pointed at and she goes,
teddy bear.
And my wife was surprised cause she didn't know she could say that.
And she goes,
my wife goes,
that's right,
teddy bear.
And then my daughter just put her right hand up and she goes,
hi,
five
like fucking bore rat.
And my wife said she fucking like,
oh,
like just keeled over laughing and what's awesome is my daughter.
Like she understands that Shit's funny now.
So now it's the cutest thing ever.
She laughs and after she left she goes funny.
It's just,
it's the greatest thing ever and it's killing me that I'm out here.
So thank you to whoever invented Skype and facetime and all that.
So that's,
that's been helping me out.
Yeah.
But um,
I'm coming down to the end of it here.
I got a,
uh,
I've got to kill a new hour then I'm very proud of and I can't wait to fucking
unleash this and let it go.
And then just see,
you know,
you know where the next hour leads me.
Uh,
and with that I got to give a shout out here to an amazing musician I saw
tonight,
uh,
Victoria Sharp.
I was in this cigar bar.
I wasn't going to smoke a cigar before my,
uh,
special,
but I had,
I kind of gave in,
I just had to go have one.
You know,
they have this great place,
a puffin rooms here in Liverpool and this woman,
Victoria Sharp,
s h.
A r.
P.
E.
Mmm.
Her Instagram is at Victoria Sharp,
s h a r p.
E music and
mmm.
She was on the piano and like she was so fucking good.
It sounded like she was in the other room cause they didn't want to have her
enough playing piano while everybody was smoking.
So she was in the smoke resection and she's playing it,
you know,
she came around and she had this whole list of songs,
anything,
any songs like fucking like 200 fucking songs,
that scene.
But she just went in and I didn't really,
she started playing and after they just sound like the same artists over and
over again.
I finally that the guys I was with,
I was like,
is that that woman who was just talking to it was so good.
It sounded like a,
like a recording.
Um,
she actually at one point sang happy birthday to this do Jamie who came out to
the show
and
she sang.
It's so good.
I actually,
this is the first time I ever been like,
yeah,
happy birthdays are really good song.
Like she made happy birthday,
sounded like a fucking hit song.
So if you ever get a chance to see or checkout on music,
she's on a Instagram at Victoria Sharp with an e at Victoria Sharp music.
Um,
check her out and uh,
I mean she seems like she'd be perfect to,
if you have a private party and you just want to kill a musician that just plays
piano and can just crush it doing that,
it's not intrusive,
but it adds to the atmosphere.
Can't say enough good things about her.
And she was cool as shit when I met her.
All right.
So anyways,
thank you to everybody who came out here and Liverpool,
uh,
could not have had a great,
better time and it was a fucking honor to be here and looking forward to going
back to Scotland,
been to Glasgow a couple of times,
haven't been in awhile.
So,
uh,
those fucking lunatics,
Scottish people are fucking lunatics.
I love him.
So,
um,
then after that we go to Manchester,
then I think Birmingham,
and then it's off to London and all freckles does a special and getting really
fucking excited for this.
So,
ah,
that's it.
Enjoy the music.
And then we have
a half hour of ways.
There's the afternoon just before finding Monday morning podcast,
Thursday by last year,
five years ago.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
February 28th,
2011.
And uh,
that's it for this month.
Pay Your fucking rent still tomorrow.
All right.
Oh,
you pot heads out there sitting on the couch,
man.
Woe.
Is it like February?
I like making fun of potheads say they,
they're really fucking defensive individuals.
Um,
every once in a while I make fun of potheads on here and I get a plethora of
emails.
Speaking of emails,
uh,
if you'd like to send an email to the podcast,
send it to
bill@thempodcast.com.
That's the new email bill B I l B as in bill,
I l l@themmpodcast.com.
All right.
And uh,
yeah,
I make fun of the fucking potheads.
I make fun of him.
I was actually having,
I mean I don't give a shit if you do it or not.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck if that's your ritual.
That's what you have to do.
Do what she does.
Is she having a beer and smoking a joint at the end of the day?
Huh?
Why don't you answer that one there?
Freckle face.
I'll tell you what the difference is.
What I'm doing is legal.
What your doing is doubt.
You throw your pot smoking fucking hands in the air.
Let me finish my point.
All right.
You hemp shirt wearing motherfucker.
Um,
yeah,
that's the difference.
That's the only difference.
Cause I don't even think like as far as health goes,
I was going to say health wise,
but that,
that word doesn't exist.
I remember from my vocab improvement class way back in high school,
um,
this guy used to talk about the wiseguys health wise,
sports wise,
weather wise,
the wise guys that,
that,
those words do not exist.
Although lately ladies,
um,
lately,
uh,
the dictionaries just said fuck it.
You know,
we can't keep up with the overwhelming level of stupid people using words that
we say don't exist.
And then they just give in,
you know,
like they'll make lol,
oh,
like a legitimate word then abbreviation me,
they left a love initially sleet will the little red and 2003 they'll do shit
like that.
You know,
that's a bad example.
But then again,
I'm not exactly a great host.
All right.
You want something better?
Go to another fucking podcast.
I don't need you.
Your attitudes.
The hell was I talking about?
Oh,
I was talking about weed.
Um,
the difference that difference.
I was talking to a buddy of mine last night,
we were out in a sports bra.
Um,
we're actually watched the,
uh,
the Celtics clippers great game.
And uh,
it's awesome to see the clippers are good.
And I'm also really,
really,
really nervous about getting rid of a Kendrick Perkins.
I don't get that.
I just felt a big sigh of relief from everybody on the,
uh,
on the Lakers bench.
Oh,
thank God.
We don't have to deal with that guy fucking making us be men,
you know,
bitch slapping us in a fucking paint like we deserve.
That's why Pau Gasol,
his face is so fucking thin.
He took a slap from Perkins on both side of is hey,
give him a double,
remember killer Khan,
he gave him one of those,
uh,
during the first time we met him in the finals.
Then he had that deer in the,
I look for the rest of the fucking series.
That's what happened.
Um,
and we,
yeah,
we traded them away,
but don't get too excited Laker fans.
Cause I got a feeling those fucking the thunder are going to take you out.
You know,
I think you guys a ride.
Thank you.
You've,
if you had your moment,
you had your moment,
the fucking Sun.
But don't worry.
Don't worry.
I heard through the fucking grapevine that a dad,
what's his face there?
That Goddamn,
he looks like one of those transformers.
Who's the guy apply.
I'm so bad when I want to talk about who,
what the fuck is the Twite Howard I heard through the grapevine wants to be a
fucking or can you believe that shit?
Can you believe that shit?
You know.
Can Coby have any more championships?
Just laid at his fucking feet.
Overrated.
Koby Bryant.
Three out of his five fucking rigs.
Fucking ugh.
No stupid Laker fans.
The MVP,
MVP,
anytime he does anything just drives me up the fucking wall.
The guy got shack in his prime with Phil Jackson,
you know,
and all these morons Laker fans and be like,
well Jordan had them.
Jordan had him when he was a fucking nobody with no experience.
Okay.
Other than as a player.
He became Phil Jackson with,
with,
with the bowls,
you know what I mean?
You fucking morons.
He knew how to win.
He knew how to take big stars in Moulton together.
That's what the fuck he got.
And that's what he got with shack.
And then he still pulled the fucking team apart.
Still pulled them apart.
I don't know if he gets fucking Dwight Howard.
Fuck him and his in the last two championships I respected.
All right,
but those first three,
give me a fucking break.
Okay.
You Take Colby out of that lineup and you put me in there and that little
fucking frilly,
golden purple uniform with my ghost white legs.
We're still going to win 50 games.
I'm just going to be feed and check and he's going to turn around with this
tongue sticking out the side of his mouth.
Like some special needs kid trying to put blocks in around circle.
Right.
Ah,
really?
Did you have to attack those people bill?
Sorry,
I'm going off the dome.
Um,
anyways,
let's get back to fucking pot here.
All right.
This is,
this is,
this is the conversation I had.
Oh,
I know.
So,
um,
I went to this,
this Boston sports bar last night,
and for the first time since I can fucking remember,
I had a good experience as a fan because,
uh,
and I mean almost you guys who listen to this,
you know,
even the over there and jolly old England,
you're cozy,
smug cuts,
right?
If you're a fan of Liverpool,
you pretty much live in Liverpool,
right?
Isn't that our police when you're young,
but then you move away and not only do you feel weird rooting on your team,
your people are telling you that they suck at it.
It's unreal.
Since 1995,
I moved to New York City and then it went from everybody loving the red sox to
absolutely hating their existence.
And then I moved out to la and everybody hates the Celtics.
And,
um,
not to mention the awful vibe of sports fans out here in,
uh,
on the west coast.
They are fucking horrific.
I Dunno why ESPN spends the lion's share of their time when they talk about
awful fans just talking about Philly,
you know,
just recycling those same two fucking stories about Santa Claus and a,
I don't know what else they did.
They fucking,
what did they do?
And they raped like Kathie Lee Gifford sent.
What happened?
I can't fucking rubber anyways.
Um,
yeah,
just out here.
The vibe.
It's just not fun out here.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
I can't explain it.
It's like back east obnoxious shit-talking morons.
Right.
And I include myself as one of those,
but eventually it dies down and you'll start talking about the game.
You'll start talking about games you went to,
you start talking sports.
It goes beyond a fuck you,
you fucking chattery and fig.
It goes beyond that.
Out here.
It never does.
And when it does,
it goes on to a,
I'll stab you in the parking lot.
It's not fun out here.
I don't know what it is.
There's that.
I will stab you in the fucking people get stabbed at Games out here.
It's hilarious.
Like that movie,
the warriors,
it's fucking ridiculous.
You Ucla and USC played at the Rose Bowl.
Okay.
And people got stabbed.
Yeah.
And they're talking about Philly cause they through batteries at Santa Claus.
What would you rather have?
Would you rather be dressed like a holiday icon?
Taken a fucking Duracell do the head or do you,
would you rather take a steak knife to the gut through your game?
Worn Jersey out in the parking lot to bleed out on the fucking 17th hole outside
of the Rose Bowl?
I don't fucking know.
So anyways,
can I,
so I,
I,
what am I,
I don't want to say anything.
You know,
you're stuttering.
Prick.
Um,
um,
so I went to this,
I went to this sports bar,
there was just a Boston sports bar and it was fucking great.
Like the Celtics did something good and I was almost self conscious to chair.
I'm so beaten down by living out here and everybody was going nuts and it was
just such a fucking relief.
It was awesome.
And I have decided,
fuck staples center.
I'm not going to the games down there.
Um,
even Dodgers games are surprisingly not fun.
I had a buddy of mine showed up to a Dodgers game.
You're playing some of the National League team and he's from Cleveland.
He had a Cleveland Indians hat on.
He's out in the bleachers and this guy started like legitimately saying,
I'm going to kick the shit out of you if you don't take that Cleveland Indians
hat off fucking Indians.
They haven't won since 1948.
Who gives a fuck?
So anyways,
I have,
fuck,
I'm never going to get back to the weed here.
I'm going to have to stick with this fucking story.
So last week as you,
you know,
I cut the podcast short cause I,
someone hooked me up and I went to the,
uh,
to the all star game to go down there and watch some of the greatest athletes on
the planet and of course check out the WHO is.
Um,
and I was not disappointed.
I'm fucking amazing basketball.
Um,
and the level of whore,
uh,
just every fucking tear.
Okay.
The desperate horror,
the horror live down the fucking street,
all the way up to the whore who flew in for the fucking game,
who's been doing p nine dx for the last fucking eight months,
you know,
did some sort of cleanse and was just in unbelievable shape.
Just fucking trying to figure out how to get in to an after party to get into
the hotel and there was fucking awesome.
So anyways,
I get,
I get this insane hookup,
right?
I'm not trying to big league you guys here.
All right.
But I got it.
I got a great,
I got a great fucking hookup and I was in one of those,
uh,
one of the luxury boxes,
one of the 90 million luxury boxes that they have at staples center.
They have like three,
three levels of them.
Um,
and I'm sitting there and I'm like,
oh,
finally I'm in staples center.
It's not a Lakers game.
It's not a clippers game.
Then I play in the Celtics.
I don't have to listen to Boston sucks the entire time I'm here.
Right.
And all of a sudden,
hang on a second.
Does that my phone.
Can you hear that?
Where the fuck is my phone?
He,
that gay little ring.
That's my phone.
Where is it?
Bomb bubba bone bum Ba ba bum.
Anybody else had the fucking droid?
Yeah,
that
Dun Duh Dun Duh.
The reason why I picked that is because I,
there's like 10 options for a ringtone on the droid and the first nine sound
like an air raid.
You now bap bap,
bap or they take this,
this ringing that just,
it just puts me on edge.
So the only thing that one's called waterfall,
I think it is.
So I have it set on that and every time I do need it goes,
what are you afraid?
But I say like,
I liked that one.
So anyways,
so I got box seats for the fucking all star game.
It's ridiculous,
right?
Um,
and I'm sitting there and I got a holy,
now I bought like an all star tee shirt,
you know,
total fucking nerd fan.
And I go to the game,
I'm thinking this is great.
So finally have to deal with shit.
Talk at people,
right?
I'm sitting there watching the game and all of a sudden this little kid voice,
seven,
eight year old,
when when doc rivers put out the big three from the Celtics,
I just start hearing this kid going anytime a Celtic shoot the ball,
he go
yelling this shit right the entire fucking time I go,
you gotta be shitting me.
You gotta be shitting me.
Really?
You're going to heckle at a fucking all star game,
you idiot.
Right?
And then they go to sit the big three from uh,
the Celtics,
right?
And then I hear this guys voice go,
go [inaudible] I'm like,
what kind of a fucking moron yells at,
at an all star game.
And I look over,
I'm not going to say who it was,
but uh,
it was a rapper,
very famous rapper who is being just a rapper,
you know,
has traveled the fucking world.
And I'm literally sitting there going,
cause I was looking at the kid going,
this kid sounds like a 35 year old asshole,
you know,
who calls in like a sports talk radio kind of thing.
Why is he behaving that way?
And then I look,
oh cause his dad is an asshole.
It would would've just sent out,
just come in and ended up,
you know,
the experience end up stuff.
But I will give this to them.
At least they weren't.
They were making some noise.
I don't if you guys watch the all star game.
It was the worst crowd I've ever seen in my life.
The problem was because the entire lower level was either former players,
whores or some form of celebrity or somebody managing a celebrity.
And uh,
everybody just sat there.
I mean,
I could have yelled from where I was sitting and someone on the court could have
fucking heard me.
But,
um,
I dunno.
I still like that rappers albums,
at least the stuff from the late eighties,
early nineties.
You're eventually going to figure this out.
But uh,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
do you ever have the urge to throw in eight year old off a fucking mezzanine
level?
I didn't want to do that,
but you know,
it's just like,
will you shut the fuck up?
Just shut up.
All of Ya.
Ali is shut up and he can make a fucking lay up to shut up already.
It's a fucking all star game.
So anyways,
let's get back to the weed.
Let's get back to the weed.
So,
so I go to the sports bar and I'm hanging out and we started talking about,
you know,
I'm still not boozing,
right?
135 fucking days here.
People,
this is getting serious.
You know,
this is like,
I,
I sort of hung out with somebody in a cult and you're like,
yeah,
it bills too smart for this shit,
you know?
And then one day I show up with the shaved head and that glassed over,
look at my eye,
talking about waiting for the spaceship.
I'm 135 fucking days in people.
I don't know if I'm coming back.
Oh,
you fucking booze hounds out there.
I think you might have lost me.
Ah,
the urge is still there.
Her Gun,
I'd love to tear down a fucking fierce did.
Um,
so anyways,
so we were talking about the difference between,
you know,
booze versus weed and um,
and I,
I basically told them,
I said,
yeah,
and I don't think there's anything,
especially now with like a vaporizer,
um,
I don't,
you know,
that has to be way more healthier than drinking like three beers and that,
seriously,
that's another thing too.
Like when,
when potheads go like,
you know,
you come home after work,
you have a beer,
I smoke a joint.
It's like,
no dude,
that there's different,
I drink a beer,
I'm not drunk.
You know,
you smoke a joint that's like drinking.
Like what three,
four beers,
I think it is.
Anyways,
whatever.
So this,
this is what I think the difference is.
I think the fact,
because weed is not legal,
that's why it leads to other drugs.
You basically,
you left the legal world and now you've dipped your toe into illegal.
And I think it's really easy to go from weed to be like,
Eh,
shrooms,
you know,
it's his cousin.
It's no biggie.
I have you,
you know,
and then there's this and then cocaine is kind of further in the back of that
room.
And then right behind cocaine is a big steel fucking door.
Like that maniac used to come out of in the,
in the Texas chainsaw massacre.
You slide that fucker opening in there.
That's where it,
heroin,
meth,
oxy and all that shit is in there.
All right.
Which I don't think just because you smoke weed that you go to that,
but they're there.
That's what I will say that Lena,
when when people who smoke weed go,
dude,
it doesn't lead the harder drugs and yeah,
it does.
I think it does.
It doesn't always,
you know this people who smoked crack and they don't become addicted,
they try.
I tried it once,
I was like whatever.
And then other people lose their entire lives.
There is exceptions to it being up,
but being honest with me potheads all right.
Like I,
this one,
I want to know how many people out there have just tried just,
you know,
Ben drunk,
tried alcohol I guess is what I'm trying to say.
Never tried weed,
but did try mushrooms like I've done two drugs,
alcohol and mushrooms,
you know,
alcohol and coke.
I bet you would be hard pressed to find somebody who doesn't have weed in there.
It goes bear,
we'd shrooms or beer,
weed,
coke,
depending on what you want to feel.
Right.
If you want to hallucinate or if you want to feel like Charlie Sheen.
Huh.
How fucking amazing was that whole thing?
I loved all,
I'm on Twitter by the way.
I finally gave in,
Joe Rogan signed me up to drop a fucking name there.
Uh,
I was doing his,
uh,
awesome podcast,
which you guys should all check out.
Um,
I was doing his podcast and he was beside himself that I wasn't signed up to
Twitter and I've been shitting all over Twitter,
tweeting and all that type of thing saying I don't want to fucking do it.
And I'm gradually becoming addicted to it.
And of course I don't have,
we'll have it up on the [inaudible] podcast.com where I'm,
where I'm located.
I've been,
uh,
you know,
I learned how to attach pictures and uh,
I feel like a little schoolgirl right now.
I'm all excited.
I'm cutting and pasting.
I'm typing,
socializing.
Um,
ah fuck.
What the hell was I talking about that I feel okay.
Weed coke,
a Texas chain,
so that massacres,
oh you can't bill.
What is wrong with your brain?
My brain goes in,
it goes in a straight line.
If I tried to go back,
I'm fucked.
The fuck was I talking about?
Oh,
Charlie Sheen.
There we go.
Thank God Charlie Sheen.
Alright,
I'm gonna have to start doing this thing live so I can start taking college just
for that specific thing that when I lose my train of thought,
they could just tell me what the fuck I was talking about or I could get an
assistant,
you know,
you could do something like that.
Charlie shame.
I was amazed at the amount of people that took what he was saying at face value.
Kathie Lee Grifford to bring her up again.
She was like,
I thought his statements were selfish.
They were self centered.
It was like,
you don't think he was high?
I can't say it was high because that would be slandered.
But what the fuck?
Why is my voice cracking?
I know because I was yelling and that Sports Bra,
what the fuck?
When it's time to change?
Um,
that guy,
he sounded like he sounded okay for the legal department,
not Slagle Love Cook.
He sounded like somebody high on cocaine,
you know?
Right.
When you're hitting that peak before the paranoia comes in from what I've heard,
not so you guys think that I'm out there doing coke.
I can't do it.
I'm too fucking paranoid as it is.
You know,
that I'm,
the shit right up the mountain would be,
would be very short for me and then it would just go right down to,
I think everybody's watching me.
Uh,
I'm gonna go,
go hide in a fucking broom closet.
Um,
yeah,
he just sounded like he was fucking high out of his mind and I was actually kind
of annoyed by the guy who was interviewing him because I just felt like he was
sort of enabling them,
you know,
and like you kind of saw in that at least I'm totally judging this because who
knows?
I don't know either one of those fucking guys,
but it was like he is,
see how celebrities Odi because people are just so psyched to be fucking around
them that they look the other way.
The guy at one point goes like,
uh,
you know,
I saw you the other day.
You seem fine.
You know,
we were at your house in your media room watching apocalypse now.
He,
you seem fine.
It's like you fucking star Fucker gimme a god that you're,
you're with Charlie Shane watching apocalypse now in his media.
Roman is fucking mansion.
There's no way you're going to criticize them in that moment.
That would be like me hanging out with Jimmy page watching the song remains the
same.
He's falling down drunk and he looks at me like,
Hey mate,
you think I've got a drinking problem?
Ah,
Jimmy,
you're fine.
Hey,
can I play one of these?
Gets I can have the guitar,
dude,
you're awesome.
Okay.
Who the fuck?
I mean,
there's no way you're going to criticize anybody.
You know,
if I could go a fucking watch the godfather over Al Pachino his house.
Well,
I guess that's,
that's not the same because Charlie Sheen's not in apocalypse now.
Whatever.
Al Pachino have any kids.
You know what the Fuck I'm saying?
I don't know.
So whatever.
I felt bad for the guy.
I hope he,
uh,
you don't hope he turns his life around.
But I also felt that he,
I thought he made some decent points.
There was a lot of points in there.
I was just like,
hey,
you know,
skis,
he sort of hands on
Imam lined.
He actually,
I only listened to half that shit.
I'm all right.
Before we get into the podcast here,
can I tell you about the content?
The bank that I ran into this week?
Can you hear it?
What the fuck is my fucking phone?
Okay.
What the hell is it?
All right.
Do you guys really want to listen to,
to hunt for my fucking phone?
The hunt for Red October.
Um,
all right.
So I'm sitting outside my bank,
you know,
cause I worked hard all weekend.
Why would I want the money when I can just go and give it to these Steve and
motherfuckers?
Oh sure I can have it at home.
Right then I got to worry that people will figure out that I'm,
I'm cashing my checks and I'm bringing them home.
And next thing you know,
the outside of my apartment looks like the end scene at the end of fucking scar
face,
right?
Bunch of sweaty,
long haired Psychos,
you know,
climbing over my nonexistent walls and behind all of them.
Some guy who's watched walking is slow as Jason and Friday the 13th knowing that
he's going to get the fucking kill shot.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm sitting outside the bank and I'm on a conference call,
you know,
talking about some bullshit,
pitching some fucking idea,
you know,
hey,
we'll take 10 whores,
we'll stick them in a house and we'll call it the fucking whore challenge.
And if fucking we'll get fucking Bob Saget the host or whatever the fuck I was
saying.
Right.
So as I'm sitting there outside the back in the parking lot in my car,
uh,
this home in this lady pulls up and this Mercedes right and I'm on the phone.
She opens the door right into my fucking car.
Boom.
Does it look at my car,
closes her car door and just walks into the fucking bank.
And I was sitting there like beside myself going,
did she just open the car door into my fucking car?
Cause she sought a mind fuck me.
Cause I heard it,
but she didn't do a,
or Oh my God,
I'm sorry she didn't look.
She just act like it didn't even happen.
I was like,
you know,
you know the hybrid,
because it goes from like the gas engine to the electric tangents sometimes when
it,
when it turns over,
it causes the car to shake a little bit.
And sometimes like when I'm on of my podcasts at time where I thought that guy
rear ended me,
that's what happened.
So I was like,
this is that some sort of hybrid shit or whatever.
So I go back to the phone conversation here.
She comes out again and now you know,
I'm looking at her,
you know,
she's got little midriff showing,
a little blondie and I'm like already starting to judge her and she comes
walking again,
opens the car door right into my car.
So I'm on this conference call with like fucking industry people.
I'd go,
Hey,
can you guys hang on a second,
I should have hit mute.
And I didn't.
All right,
so I put,
I beeped the horn and I go,
I go,
hey,
hey.
I put the window down.
She's like,
what?
I go,
you just opened your door into my car.
I did.
Yes,
you did it on the way into the bag or on the way out.
She was like,
well I didn't chip the paint.
That's what she said.
And I was like,
what do you may need a chip to pay you or you didn't even look,
how would you know?
Why don't you be a little more considerate next time and look what the hell
you're doing.
Boom.
And I slammed the door shut.
Right.
So I go back to the car,
I go,
sorry about that.
Guys are like,
Oh lets everything go right over that bill.
No,
it isn't.
All right.
You heard what happened?
You fucking jerk.
You don't have any,
you know,
you don't have
the uh,
you know confrontations,
right.
So she goes,
uh,
then I just hear her with my window up.
I can just hear her going,
have a nice day,
smile.
She starts doing that shit.
Like I'm this asshole like me getting upset that you opened your fucking car
doors.
We twice without a care in the world.
Like my natural reaction is not supposed to get upset.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
You know,
I don't believe in that whole heaven and Hell Shit,
but I think that that episode right there is,
you know,
if there is this whole judgement that was one in favor of me,
the fact that I didn't call her a cunt,
you know right there.
You know what I mean?
She's given me the finger like somehow she's been wrong.
I swear to God,
dude,
I just wanted to take my fucking passenger side door,
open it up and fucking like three fucking times,
right into a goddamn car and then just go,
hey,
did shift the pate.
This is why I didn't.
Two reasons.
One,
because it was a broad,
all right,
it was a guy,
I wouldn't do it because what if he comes over and beats the shit out of me who
say cous kitten home.
Okay.
You know,
if you want to have like a,
a street fight,
like a brother on brother fight,
where we both end giving each other in,
you know,
in simultaneous headlocks going,
you give,
I'll have a fight like that.
But I,
you know,
average random dude,
I'm not fighting the guy in 42 fucking years old.
Okay,
I'm gonna get my ass kicked.
But now there was a woman,
I can't do it because
she could get out of her fucking car and just starts smashing up my car.
And there's really nothing I can do to try and physically stop her because she's
a lady.
Right?
And that's the first reason.
And then the second reason is I've watched enough sports to realize that,
uh,
the reps always see the retaliation.
They never see the initial thing.
So it's like,
she fucking hits me twice.
Nobody sees it.
And then I fucking slam Mike and then I,
you know,
I would be like,
hey,
she did it to me first and I would fucking loose.
So I didn't do anything at a,
Oh,
the fucking thoughts I had afterward of wishing I followed her.
You know,
in my quiet hybrid to wherever the hell she lived.
And I wanted to carve into her driver's side door either cunt.
And I was like,
ah,
that's on.
That's on original.
I love,
I wanted to carve in.
I didn't ship the paint and to the,
or maybe I did chip the paint,
lol laughing my ass off OMG.
Or is there some dumb shit?
You know what if I,
you know,
you know what kills me is she's out there.
You know,
she probably told the story later on that day where I would just,
I would love to hear her version of that fucking story,
uh,
how she was the victim.
You know,
it's just,
I can tell who's,
because she was hot and she's not used to somebody actually calling her on her
shit.
Or if she's a product of the combination,
the timeout generation and that generation for the last fucking 35,
I don't know,
35 years for the last,
I don't have 25 fucking years.
The parenting,
at least in this country,
I don't know what happened.
It's like it went from when I was a kid where whatever your neighbor said you
did,
your parents believed,
whatever your teacher said you did,
your parents,
whatever,
and adults said that you were doing and you are out of a low in your outer line.
Parents just said,
oh,
is that what he's doing?
I'm going to have a talk with them.
Mr. Robinson down the street says,
yeah,
you jumped over his fats.
You will,
you want,
you were jumping in his pool and then you tried to ladder up.
Give me that shit.
Get upstairs.
You go on your fucking rub you.
But whatever.
They don't do that anymore.
The last like 25 years.
It's like if,
uh,
if uh,
somebody says something to somebody,
hey,
basically your kids being a fuck head right now,
they just automatically defend their kid straight through the whole thing.
They defend their kid.
You can't go to somebody's house.
You can have a fucking play date.
You don't get the shit kicked out of you that you don't get hit or anything.
You get a time out,
you know,
and then I think,
25 fucking years later,
you're in a bank fucking opening you goddamn door into somebody's car.
You're a surprise that they're mad and beat.
Don't think you did anything fucking wrong.
Timeout.
Look at hockey.
You go in to beat the shit out of somebody.
They just make the guys sit down for five minutes,
you know,
does he learn anything?
They keep comes out,
he fucking pizza him up again.
Hey,
by the way,
I bought those Bruins.
Huh?
Beaten a very,
very,
very strong Vancouver conduct team.
I was a big fucking victory for us,
but I think before and Oh,
and the fucking road trip.
Jayode all right,
let's get to the topics for this week.
Um,
topic number one for the classic,
is it racist,
racist,
racist.
Um,
Oh,
before I get it to get into
that,
before we get to that,
um,
here's something you might want to read up on last week when I was talking about
the,
uh,
the whores that go to the all star game and that type of shit.
Um,
there's somebody sent me an article that we will have linked on the,
uh,
the [inaudible] podcast.
Dot.
Uh,
was an article that came out in 2006 in Gq magazine where one of the writers
hung out with some Groupie,
some NBA groupies and that type of thing.
And,
um,
what is really,
it's a really interesting article and what is also really interesting is she
never really gets to talk to any of the horrors that are really doing the dirt.
You know what I mean?
She talks to three girls who,
well,
we might if it happened,
but who knows.
We're just here to have fun.
Uh,
that's how tight that circle is.
It's really interesting article.
I'll have the link up on the MM podcast.com the official Pan Fan page of the
Monday morning podcast.
And now let's get to the topic.
Is it right there?
Um,
all right,
bill,
while flipping the channels the other night I happened to catch the end of
America's funniest home videos.
Um,
The family.
That one on this particular night was a white family with what I assumed was an
adopted black daughter,
uh,
who was maybe six or seven years old.
Anyways,
after they announced the winners,
the host shook each of the family member's hands,
but when he got to the little girl,
he put his hand up and ask for a high five,
which immediately made me live it.
I'm not saying it was necessarily racist,
but I hate it when white people call me brother or want to give me complicated
handshakes when they barely know me.
Can you please tell your listeners to knock that shit off?
Lol.
Um,
you know,
it's fucking funny about that is,
yeah,
I agree with you.
It isn't racist,
but it is a,
uh,
in knowing sort of a pandering or ingratiating yourself to black culture.
Yeah,
I can see.
I,
I know what you're saying.
I just don't know how to verbalize it.
The only way I can really describe it as you guys,
anybody out there by that P90x I recommended it's great.
I just go on the road so I can't do the Diet.
So it didn't work for me,
but nick has been doing it lately and she brought up something,
I forgot what's really funny on those tapes.
I don't,
I can't remember the names of the people there,
but there's like,
you know,
a white guy like two white chicks and then a black dude.
So he goes around the room saying hello to everybody.
This is Pam.
They call their blam.
Right.
And he just,
you know,
go to,
this is Jerry's a taekwondo guy,
watch out for this guy.
You know,
this is so and so blah,
blah blah,
blah.
And then he walks up to the black guy and let's just say his name is like,
you know,
whatever James.
And he goes and he'd be like,
what's up James?
My brother,
every fucking disc.
He calls him my brother and then he goes like high pitch my bread and it's,
it's so,
uh,
on a Deuce chills from the opiate Anthony,
I think,
believe opie and Anthony came up with that expression,
or that's at least where I heard it first dose chills every time I hear that.
Um,
I totally agree with you.
I don't think it's racist,
it's just some sort of,
it's like if you met somebody Asian,
would you bow,
you know,
ads?
Yeah,
I get that.
That's fucking funny.
Um,
I,
and I've been guilty of doing a semi,
you know,
that the,
the,
the handshake,
uh,
I,
I don't know the mainstream one
was,
it grabbed the thumb slide of the hand,
the snap thing.
That thing was there for awhile and I don't even fucking know,
but I will not do a fist bump with anybody,
even if,
uh,
even if there's a black guy there,
I still won't do it.
I'll just assume that he's still hanging out with too many white people and
that's why he's still doing,
uh,
a pound.
Um,
all right,
next one.
Um,
hey bill [inaudible].
I just finished up a conversation on Facebook with some female friends of mine.
Um,
long story short,
I asked if they were on Twitter.
They replied,
we don't Twitter.
And I replied,
all right,
well whenever you ladies realize that you're missing out on the greatest social
network since the underground railroad,
just follow me at any wrote his Twitter name.
He say,
what was my comment?
Racist in your opinion?
Um,
no.
First of all,
you guys,
you've got to let me know what race you are too.
So I'm assuming that you're white now that isn't racist.
That's what overly sensitive people would think that it's racist because you
made a reference to something that involved,
uh,
the they do.
This happens to me a lot in stand up where people don't look at the context in
which you're saying something.
You're basically saying the underground railroad is the greatest social network,
or Twitter's the greatest one since the underground railroad.
So doesn't that mean that you think that the underground railroad was a great
thing?
The underground railroad was,
was Africans escaping slavery?
So,
no,
I think it's actually,
it's a good reference.
I think you're guilty of making a good reference,
but if you're around a bunch of overly sensitive people,
they would immediately think because you brought up something that had to do
with slavery on some level that you somehow advocate advocated slavery.
Um,
that happens a lot in stand up where people don't listen to what you're saying.
Or if you make a reference to slavery,
they then think that,
well,
because you made a reference to it,
then you obviously advocate it.
Um,
um,
so no,
I don't think that that is a,
uh,
I don't think that that's racist.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Next one is a right age man.
Hey,
uh,
bill,
here's one for you.
I'm 35,
but when I was about 23 for some reason I went to a bunch of stores looking for
a specific CD CDs back when they had those things.
Um,
so I come from a middle class family and went to high school,
high school.
That was like nine.
Oh two one.
Oh,
it was almost entirely white.
So I find myself in this store looking for what I thought was a CD by Snoop Dogg
.
I felt like an idiot and I'm standing in there and Khakis and a polo while a the
other white kid behind the counter reads a list of available CD titles by Snoop
Dogg.
Um,
as I try to remember the name that I'm looking for,
all right.
It didn't really set that up.
So he goes into the story,
he finds another white kid to works there.
He's dressed in Khakis and polos and says that he's looking for a snoop Dogg CD.
So now the white kid behind the counter is reading off titles of Snoop Dogg
albums.
He goes,
try to imagine him,
the white kid looking down at the computer screen and him reading the title.
He goes,
snoop upside and then looking at me straight in the eyes,
finishing sarcastically with your head,
snoop upside your head,
I guess it was the name of the album.
And he goes,
I never felt so white,
lol discourage.
I leave for another store across the street in the mall.
As I walk in,
I immediately spot one of the token black kids that graduated with me.
Uh,
now right there,
that's an offensive,
that's offensive to a lot of people.
Token black kids,
you know,
that's when you go to the all white school.
And then there was like one black kid.
The kid's always called the token.
So that's offensive all the way to racist depending on how I would think.
Um,
but whenever,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
so anyways,
he sees,
you know,
the one black kid,
he basically went to high school with how he said,
I was like,
thank God lol.
I stop him and say,
Antwan,
listen man,
he throws in a man.
I have a question for you.
What is the name of that snoop Dogg CD with the Blah,
blah,
blah song on it.
Of course there was the awkward,
what are you asking me?
You asked me because I'm black,
right?
Is the question he asked and as I'm standing there stumped for a response,
he said,
it's not snoop,
it's not snoop Dogg,
it's Dr Dre and the CD is the chronic.
Uh,
he said,
now feeling like a true idiot.
I try to make some ridiculous small talk.
That's fucking hilarious.
Uh,
I knew I went to the right source as he confirmed,
but what are your thoughts?
Is that racist now?
Now it's not racist.
The token black guy thing.
I thought of everything you said was the thing that I would,
would raise the red flag where I would,
if I was in a conversation with you.
You know,
that shit where at one white guys talking to another white guy who doesn't know.
Then out of nowhere or something sort of in the gray area comes into the
conversation and from,
you know,
then there's always that tense moment of like,
is this going to take a fucking right turn down to an unpaved road
down to a shack?
Um,
no,
it isn't.
It's not racist at all.
And it was proven because he knew the fucking answer yet.
Maybe you're,
maybe you're guilty of racially profiling.
I think you went really efficient.
It's not like you didn't try to ask another white kid.
He had no idea.
And he was a cunt.
He almost seemed like he was judging you because you are a,
you,
you were buying the music or in generally just didn't like rap music,
but you saw the black dudes you went to school with.
That's fucking,
what are you asked me because I'm black.
You should've said yes.
What am I supposed to ask some redneck?
Well,
what would happen if I walked up to you when ask,
Hey,
what,
what's,
what's the name of that new Travis tread album?
He probably like,
what the fuck are you asking a black guy that question for,
you know,
if somebody came up to me and said,
hey bill,
what's the name of that beer?
That Dev that's famous that Ireland bakes,
I wouldn't get offense.
I wouldn't get offended by that.
You know?
Or if they assumed that I drank because I'm Irish,
even though mostly German.
All right.
But I bought it because I have,
I don't get offended when people assume that I'm mostly Irish mean.
It's not like I don't look like a fucking Leprechaun.
Um,
I think that that falls into,
uh,
being overly sensitive,
but I feel that guys entitled to considered considering he seemed like he was
the only black guy.
His school and other white kids referred to him as the token.
And despite all that,
he was still nice enough to tell you what CD to buy.
See that?
That had a nice warm,
fuzzy ending.
All right,
another one,
dear bill.
Hey,
by the way,
my breathing's getting a lot better.
I got to pat myself on the back,
the pip,
pip,
pat myself on the back.
My speaking still sucks.
Oh geesh.
Dear Bill,
I recently moved to downtown Denver from Fort Collins.
Oh,
Jesus.
Is that up near Greeley,
Colorado where they have the bad smell day?
I know I've talked about this before in the podcast,
but just in case there's new listeners out there in Greeley,
Colorado,
they have a slaughter house up there where a,
you know,
if you've ever wondered where your fucking hamburgers and steaks and all that
shit came from Greeley,
Colorado is a good guests.
And,
uh,
some days when it's really windy up there and they've murdered a bunch of
fucking steer a,
they have what's known as bad smell days.
And what you do is you call up the slaughterhouse and you say,
Hey,
can you,
can you fucking cool it a little bit up there?
We can smell it all the way down here.
We can smell the murder this way.
And then they actually sort of a,
I don't know what they do,
take a 15 minute break from killing the stairs or whatever.
I don't fucking know.
Uh,
steered by the way is a bull without balls.
I had no idea what that was.
I knew what a cow was.
I knew what a ball was.
I didn't know where to steer.
Was steers a bull without balls and a,
those are the things that they,
uh,
they use for all your steak and hamburger,
I believe.
I don't think they used the cows.
He was accounts for the milk.
They use the bulls to fuck the cows,
to make more cows and to make a more bowls.
And then they cut their balls off and they make them steers.
Is that our works?
Right.
Then I learned that in my travels out there on the road,
correct me if I'm wrong.
They're southerners.
What are you asking me?
Because I'm from the south.
Yes.
You pick fucking jackass.
Answer the question.
All right,
here we go.
Dear Bill,
I recently moved to downtown Denver from a,
from a from Fort Collins,
a small college town north of Denver.
The only black people I had a had been used to seeing.
We're either exchange students from Africa or Colorado State football,
basketball players.
My new home in Denver is a neighborhood that is known for having a high black
population.
To cut to the point I've noticed while driving around my place that black
people,
generally younger black guys,
do not respect jaywalking laws at all.
I noticed that this,
I noticed this after the fifth time in one day that a black dude had walked
right out into traffic expecting that the drivers would hit their brakes and
wait for him to cross the street.
Now I see now I see this happen every day.
When I got home,
I brought it to the attention of my roommates and girlfriend and they thought I
was crazy.
But soon enough,
they all began to notice this phenomenon.
And now it's a big inside joke amongst us.
Uh,
also,
I don't know if you've seen that.
There are quite a few popular youtube videos that show exactly what I'm talking
about.
One video that I think you may have talked about showed a black guy dances way
into traffic until an ice cream truck put a stop to that.
Is it racist that I noticed this also?
Is this just a Denver thing or does it happen elsewhere?
Uh,
jaywalking happens,
uh,
I think all over the world in every race does it as far as I know.
Um,
this one is a little complex because there's a lot of levels to this cause you
don't seem like you have hatred in your heart.
MMM.
And also I haven't been to enable it.
If that's what people do,
you know,
then that's what they do there.
I lived in New York City and we all do it all,
everybody 80 year old fucking,
uh,
women from the aster family,
Jay walk when then you know,
over to their fucking town car to go visit their bars of gold.
Um,
everybody jaywalks so I wouldn't,
I wouldn't,
yeah,
obviously it's black people aren't the only ones who jaywalk but a in your
neighborhood if that's what everybody does.
Uh,
I mean that's not racist to notice that,
uh,
I think to,
to just say that it's just black people.
Um,
I don't,
I have,
you know what this is,
these,
these are getting,
these are getting difficult cause I got to hear what you're doing with that
information.
You know,
you did have your little clan moment where you convinced the people that you're
living with.
I'm telling you,
go out there,
go out there and look at them and then they came back.
Oh wait,
shit,
your rack now how offensive it is.
It that just because you know you're from Denver.
Why am I giving you a southern accent?
See we're all full of shit here.
Um,
ah fuck.
I just had a point there,
what the hell was I going to try to make?
Yeah.
I mean,
I'd have to know if you would just say in like,
you know,
if you take it to the level I guess,
uh,
well you're,
you're going let you know,
I,
you know,
the obvious level to take this where it would obviously be racist if you would
just like,
we gotta get,
we gotta get all the black people out of this country.
There are all these Jay walking such a bitches,
they're Rowan in this country or ah,
you know,
I don't want my daughter dating a black guy.
Why?
Cause they're Jay walking sons of bitches of what do I mean?
I don't fucking know if you just sort of noticing this and you,
and you think it's funny that they do this shit kind of like when I do that
older agent thing,
I don't have anything and get agents or a old people,
it'd be fucking around like,
no,
I mean,
it's probably offensive,
like my older Asian thing,
which I guess at that am I,
that game is offensive to some people.
Um,
yeah.
Is it racist
that you noticed?
I mean,
it did happen.
I guess it's when you start thinking that,
that,
uh,
all black people in general,
like Bill Cosby is walking out of his mansion and Jay walks across the street to
a,
I mean,
I dunno,
I dunno where to go with that one.
Yeah.
Now,
but I'll tell you this too.
Everybody jaywalks and I am one of the major offenders of it.
I do it all the fucking time.
All right.
I don't get fucking time to walk down to the Goddamn corner.
I don't understand what the fucking point is.
I get it.
Look both ways and if there's nothing coming,
then go.
But if something's coming,
don't go.
I get that.
All right,
Jay walking.
Uh,
I think those laws are basically invented that basically.
So they a can keep traffic moving and be,
um,
don't have to clean up a lot of dead people in the street because there's a lot
of bad drivers.
And there's also a lot of people who can't see that well,
or across the street correctly.
Maybe that's why I don't fucking know.
All right,
now we're into advice.
This is one of these ones where I'm just reading too much rather than riffing is
that's what is that,
what the fuck's going on here?
You know what?
I'm going to talk about youtube videos.
Maybe they'll fucking stir up some sort of,
some sort of comedy here.
I feel like I'm on fucking meet the press.
Um,
youtube videos.
check this one.
I remember a few weeks ago when I showed that to Johnny Mack,
the QB doing all those trick shots,
uh,
somebody made an answer video,
somebody else through his fucking football helmet into the ring.
Some guy,
Alex,
I don't know if it was say this right.
Tanny,
Alex tanties video.
This is what I got to say about all these,
these trick shot QB things.
The ones that are most impressive is when they do more than one trick without an
edit.
Those are the ones that I like,
but uh,
you know,
other than that,
these are pretty impressive.
So check that one out.
Um,
his,
his is a classic Youtube Video woman beats up boyfriend keeps yelling,
fight back.
All these videos will be up on the MM podcasts and I,
this is some inside information then I'll give you,
I never named names,
all right?
But there's a friend of mine who wrote a very successful movie after watching
this video.
All right?
And in this video there is a woman beating the shit out of a guy.
A big woman.
Okay.
So think of some comedies that came out
and the last,
oh shit,
what was it?
I think it was like five years ago it came out
and,
uh,
why don't I just tell you the movies,
Norbert,
the guy I know who wrote the movie,
wrote the movie after seeing this video,
he thought this video was fucking hilarious and said that's a movie.
And then he wrote it and then again made.
And I remember standing there going,
wow,
it's that fucking easy.
You just have to sit down and do the Goddamn work,
you know?
Um,
all right,
next one,
magnetic kid.
What the fuck is that?
Did I even watched that one?
Seven year old kid claims he's magnetic.
I somehow missed that one.
I'm drunk guy on the news.
You have to see this is the best one of the week,
I think as far as fucking hilarity.
This guy is out of his mind and speaking of racist weight is by,
this guy gets really,
he's really drunk and he starts talking about his neighbors.
He goes,
now and Sally,
you one,
are you right now?
I never liked those people.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm gonna stay.
I'm going to say something racist.
Right?
And he's so drunk.
He never gets around to it.
But the,
one of the funniest things in this video,
aside from the unbelievably long pauses this guy takes between talking,
is how the,
the reporter keeps trying to give the guy the out.
He's like,
did you start drinking?
Because she was so distraught from the fire?
And the guy's like,
no,
you know,
like,
I've been drinking off.
I was drinking before the fire,
during it and after it,
you know,
that's his basically his whole vibe.
Then here's a video.
People keep sending me.
I don't know why people find this thing funny.
I find the voice over to be unbelievably annoying.
It says crazy nasty as honeybadger.
And I guess it's making fun of all the videos showing how bad ass the honey
badger is.
But this guy sounds like he's doing a really bad impression of a sitcom
character that's gay.
And uh,
he just,
he's annoying after a while a conspiracy theorists out there,
new world order documentary we have.
And um,
I actually got this one Chevy 1991 s 10 commercial.
Uh,
one of the people I follow on Youtube,
he does a bunch of a really good Zeplin covers and he throws up random videos
every once in a while.
So I saw it on his channel.
Uh,
it was both for Shard,
I believe his name is B e a u just type in that and then look up Zeplin if
you're a drummer.
Um,
he fucking kills a bunch of different Zeplin tracks and,
all right,
those are the youtube videos for this week.
And uh,
do I have anything else to talk about?
I think I was just going to fucking advice and then we'll wrap this goddamn
thing up.
We will wrap it up.
Oh this week,
by the way,
I'm going to be in Miami.
All right.
I'm going to be in Miami
at the,
uh,
the fucking fuck fest theater.
Where the hell am I going to be?
Hang on a second.
Me.
Let me get the information for you,
right.
Do you just sit tight?
You sit tight.
You're Goddamn cubicle.
All right.
Start fucking scratching your Chin as you're looking at those spreadsheets.
Like,
that's odd.
All right.
I'm at the new world symphony 517th Street,
Miami Beach,
Florida.
Also for those of you in Utah,
I added,
I added a date in March,
March 18th and March 19th.
I'm going to get wise guys in West Valley City,
Utah.
Uh,
probably going to hang around for another day to go fucking skin.
Oh,
I know what I want to tell you guys.
I finally committed to the sport of hockey.
Told you I've been playing ice hockey out here and all I had,
I had the helmet with the full cage in the front because who's kidding?
Who my dream of making it to the NHL died sometime I believe,
uh,
about 1984.
Um,
I was never good.
I always sucked.
So I would go,
I've been playing,
I helmet,
I have the full face mask and I had the gloves,
sticks,
skates.
Obviously that's all I had.
And I gotta tell you as a 42 year old man falling down on the fucking ice,
that is not a good feeling.
So I finally just said to hell with it.
And I went out and I bought all the gear,
head to toe.
I have all the fucking pads and it made a,
made all the difference in the world.
Dude,
you go down,
you don't feel anything,
you don't feel anything.
It's fucking tremendous.
It's like falling,
uhh,
falling on it.
Not Pillows,
but it's,
it's the shit.
So,
uh,
so anyway,
so what I've been doing is,
you know,
I hate going to the fucking gym,
so I,
they take my dog for a hike or recently for cardio's that they have,
you know,
they have the public skating thing.
So I'll go down there like a fucking pedophile,
you know,
42 year old single white male,
never married,
no kids.
I swear to God,
I won't even look at a child when I am in there.
I won't,
I fucking,
I just skate around and I fuckin mind my own business.
So anyway,
I go down there and a,
I basically work on shit that I suck at that you can work on it during a public
skating thing,
which is basically I suck at stop and on my right side.
So I just started working on that.
And A,
I can turn around to skate backwards,
but I'm not good.
I'm more lefthanded than I am right handed,
so I'm not good yet.
I shoot the puck right handed,
I'm fucked so I can't turn around to the right side.
Good.
So the only way you improve in life is if you attack your weaknesses.
So I start learning it right,
and I'm crossing over and over.
It's going great.
And then what happens?
I get a little cocky.
Oh,
he's right.
And I'm fucking my version of flying and probably going three quarters of the
speed that,
uh,
that I can skate and I fucking turnaround and dude,
I don't know what the fuck happened cause I,
you know,
I'll fall,
but I can fall gracefully at this point that this was like,
I had a beginner fall and I was going backwards at about 17 miles an hour and I
didn't fall in my side.
I didn't,
I didn't get my hands down,
nothing.
I fell,
I fell like a fucking tree and I landed right on my ass.
And then I got my right elbow down at the last second.
So my head didn't hit the ice,
but my brain's still smacked.
And like I was dizzy when I got up.
And Dude,
I swear to God,
I don't know how I didn't break my tailbone.
I fucking like,
my ass was killing me.
I had to s I s I skated off the ice.
That was it.
I was done.
I went off the ice and I sat down and I collected myself,
you know,
and I had snow all over my backside.
Oh,
I missed the best part of when I fell down and I fucking went to try,
kind of stayed there for half a second.
Like did I just break my fucking tail bone?
Did I really just do that?
And I,
and I didn't feel any sort of,
you know,
pain beyond,
I just busted
my ass on the ice.
So as I roll over some like 11 year old kid skates by and does this Simpson
ha ha and then keeps going.
I got to Mit,
I didn't get even get mad at him.
I was just like I said,
I know it,
I know and I know it.
And then I got up and it wasn't till I was driving home that that kid actually
annoyed me and I dreamed of cross him into the glass,
you know,
which is,
which is childish.
But uh,
yeah.
So I'm playing again this week and I'm definitely having a good time.
It's so much better than going to the gym and I'm,
I having fallen on the ice there by myself.
I have a whole new respect for like contact sports,
like people who play him at like,
you know,
professional fucking levels or even just pick up games like,
uh,
you know,
I was seriously like,
there was like,
I had to collect myself.
Like I said,
like I can't imagine doing that shit for a fucking living.
Mean skating is hard enough.
Forget about some guy trying to knock you over when you're not looking.
It's just,
it's unbelievable.
It's unfucking believable,
so it's unbelievable.
I couldn't believe it.
I'm bored with it already.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's read some advice and then I'm getting the getting the fuck outta here.
By the way,
recently I've actually thought,
I've considered about having some advertising here on the podcast and I know you
guys are thinking,
Oh gee,
he is here.
He goes,
he's going to sell out,
man.
I'm,
you're absolutely right.
I am going to sell out.
You know,
what are they going?
I want to keep it real and stay broke.
I'm not broke.
I'm doing all right,
but give me a fucking break.
Okay.
Eventually people,
I'm not going to want to jump on a goddamn airplane.
Okay.
And I don't want to charge you cons,
anything,
you know,
so,
uh,
I've been thinking about it so,
but I,
I think I can still do it in a creative cool way where I'll just have
advertisers on here of Shit that I like.
Drum companies,
booze,
uh,
you know,
Shit like that.
As long as I can read it and make fun of the copy,
I will do it.
Um,
and I'll charge everybody a dollar 75 per episode.
I dunno,
I'm going to try to figure something
out.
Um,
all right,
let's go to advice,
spill advice.
Um,
so for the last five years I've been teaching guitar lessons fulltime at a very
large music school in Chicago.
Um,
there are over a hundred music teachers at the school with about 5,000 students.
Every session,
half of those students are under 18.
The school has been around for over 50 years and is globally recognized.
Let me see if I can figure that out.
Mm.
Oh,
Chicago.
I don't know that one.
I was going guess Berkeley.
Now I get an email from the new director of the school is saying all of the
staff are required to get their thumbs scanned by some company called bio
metric.
What biometric scans your thumbs into their watch system.
We all already had a background checks done when we were hired,
but now they argue that we need to have this done.
Apparently all of the public school teachers in their entire city are being
forced to do this as well.
Basically anyone who is around any younger who was around any younger,
please,
please people please proofread your shit.
You make me sound dumb.
I'm already dumb enough.
Basically anyone who was around any younger people over for a profession is now
mandated by their employee to get in this creepy biometric system.
You see this shit?
Have you guys noticed this?
All this fucking screaming and yelling.
We do during every single election that comes around to pick the Democrat or the
Republican.
It doesn't make a difference because when the real shit goes down like
approving,
giving biometrics the right to do this,
we don't get to vote on this.
They don't even tell us about us.
They just go,
it's a law.
It's mandatory.
You have to do this.
Anyways,
he says,
I don't have anything to hide,
but the mental picture of all of us,
harmless musicians lining up like fucking cattle,
having some storm trooper assholes scanning my thumbprint into some super
computer where it will stay forever is really depressing.
Obviously this is all done in the name of air quote,
protecting the children,
but at what cost?
Here's my question for you.
I feel like this is my moment to take a stand.
Should I make a deal big deal about this and try to rally all the other teachers
to fight this or will I just look like I have something to hide?
Uh,
it is really,
really hard to get a job at this school,
so I'm scared to make waves.
Do you feel like this protects kids from creeps?
I should mention that in the schools 50 year,
his history,
no incident of a teacher,
a student misconduct has been recorded.
Everyone knows that pedophiles can't play an instrument.
Lol.
Uh,
and do you think,
um,
they are making priests get thumb scans?
I fucking bet.
Not all joking aside,
I'm really bothered by this situation.
What should I do,
Bill?
I don't know.
I,
the first thing I would do is I would talk to other teachers and see how they
feel about it.
I think that's complete horseshit though.
They have been basically working their way towards this since they first came up
with photo ids and social security numbers and all of that shit.
It's all done under the whole guise of organization in your own fucking safety.
And it's complete horseshit.
It has to do with them eventually trying to have a very few people be able to
make the decisions for all of us.
That's basically what's going on.
Okay.
And the more information they have about you,
the easier it is to be able to find you.
I mean,
think about that shit.
They're going to have your thumbprint,
they know what you're fucking fingerprint looks like.
All right.
They're going to have an a visibility to freeze your fucking bank account and
your cell phone as a goddamn microchip in it.
Okay.
So the second day,
I mean this is like end of day shit and they got these fucking robots that
they've been working on that can outperform human beings.
I'm telling you,
our days are fucking number.
They are on jeopardy.
The other day they had two human beings playing against the fucking computer.
Those two people,
they're helping human beings get phased out.
You should see I'm not competing,
gets a fucking computer so you can figure out how it does against me and you can
figure the computer's weaknesses and strong points so it can come back with even
more game and you can pump it back with more fucking information.
So eventually I become fucking useless unless of course I know how to build a
robot or know how to grease it's fucking joints.
Yeah Dude.
I think,
yeah,
I think it would be a very noble thing if you complained about that.
I think people need to complain more.
I'm guilty of it.
I fucking rant here on this podcast,
but I've never been to a protest.
But I don't think that it's right that they,
that they pass a law,
like whether you agree with that or not,
that's not something that they should be able to pass without the voice of the
people.
We should be able to vote on something like that.
That's fucking ridiculous.
I just found out from my account the other day after years of saying,
I'm not doing my shit online cause I don't want to put all that information
online.
I now have no option.
I have to do it online.
You know,
I,
I don't want to put all my fucking information online,
my tax ID numbers,
my social security numbers.
You're out of your fucking mind.
You're letting people in to your entire financial history.
You'll [inaudible] GG your whole fucking God knows what they can do with that
and they can ruin you.
All right.
All I'm doing is bitch in here,
but oh,
that's shit.
Really.
That's fucking creepy as hell.
Um,
I would talk to other people,
be like,
and a,
you know,
well,
what do you think about this?
You know,
sort of get it going.
just like how they started the revolution in this country.
Hey,
are you already thinking about those red coats?
They kind of a yet Dick's right to kind of dicks.
Yeah.
I don't like him either.
All right.
Uh,
question number two.
Hey bill,
this has been bothering me for a while now and I'm not sure what to do.
I'm 19 years old.
I go to Umass Amherst.
Oh Geez.
Um,
do that place is insane.
Do you guys still party the timeout generation?
Do you still party the way they used to where they would actually have
fatalities at that school?
People used to ride the elevators.
There was that classic urban myth about those kids bring in the cow up to the
roof of the building and they didn't know how to get it off.
So they just pushed it off to the side and it exploded into a hamburger heaven.
Um,
anyways,
I had a girlfriend my first semester of college,
uh,
that was still in high school.
We both knew that I was going,
that we both knew that I was going far away and we,
but we agreed that we would stay together.
However,
I guess her feelings changed and she wanted to be single.
I was devastated when she broke up with me and I've been really down because she
was the first girlfriend I had that I really liked.
And,
uh,
I wasn't just trying to get laid,
actually liked this girl.
So after a few weeks I found out she was hooking up with this kid that I
considered to be a friend,
a boy,
because we had been hanging out over the summer and partying together.
What's fucked up about the whole situation is that this isn't the first time
this guy has done this to me.
All right.
You know what I just thought of when I read that sentence was,
uh,
what was the,
what was the name of that movie?
Uh,
dead presidents.
You know,
when the dude comes back into the pool hall with the stick and he beats the shit
out of Terrence Howard.
I,
that's,
I'm not saying to do that,
but that's the first movie scene that came to my head.
Anyways,
at the end of my senior year,
I broke up with a different girl and this kid was hooking up with her.
About a month later,
I let that one slide.
That's your fault then if,
because he said,
because again,
I didn't really give a fuck about any other girlfriends I had before this
previous one.
Um,
I don't want to be a crazy ex boyfriend that gets defensive over girls that no
longer like him,
but should I or should I not tell this kid to back off and stop going after my
ex-girlfriends?
Uh,
you definitely need to have a talk with that dude.
You need to clear the air with them
and um,
and then you need to stop fucking with them.
That's what I would do.
And I would go somewhere along the lines of describing him as like a,
you ever see those little fish that swim under the big fish,
you know,
and I plankton,
I don't know what they fuck they are,
they swim on under the whales.
You know,
just ask them.
It's like,
dude,
do you have an ability to get pussy without drafting behind me?
Like somebody in the Tour de France,
you know,
if there was like pussy at the finish line,
the fuck is wrong with you.
You know,
I don't know.
Don't listen to me on how to say this stuff because I say fuck a lot and I'm an
angry dude.
You'll end up getting into a fist fight.
But uh,
yeah,
I would definitely say something to the kid.
Oh,
you know,
it'd be funny if you call them up,
like,
I don't know where you're from.
You know,
just say you're from,
um,
just say you're from La.
Just call them up and say,
hey,
listen,
just to let you know,
I've been recently hooking up with this chick from San Diego.
Uh,
you know,
just want to let you know,
send you a picture just to show you the next person that you're going to be
fucking cause evidently you loved sloppy seconds.
You know,
you fucking pervert you gave from me or something.
Do you just want to be where my Dick has been?
You know the love of God.
Go get yourself a boyfriend.
There you go.
Hit Him with the homophobia.
That's a good one.
Not that I advocate homophobia,
but when you use it,
it can be your friend.
Ah,
that really makes sense.
All right bill.
Hey Bill,
I'm 24 and have four kids.
Jeez,
what is it?
The fucking 18 hundreds.
What do you do?
You Go,
what do you got?
Some fucking,
they need some farm hand,
sir.
Somebody to go clean out the silo or fill it up.
Ah,
good Lord.
You guys make your own clothes.
I'm 24 and I have four kids.
I'm married.
I feel bad for this guy.
Should make fun of them.
I work for public utilities doing very hard manual labor and I work hard for my
money,
which goes straight to my wife and four kids.
Basically when politicians run for office and they try to stand on the shoulders
of hardworking Americans.
This is the guy right here.
This is the guy that like Sam Elliott talks about.
Speaking of that,
I recently saw one of those cores commercials.
Have you seen that?
The rocky mountains good down this country like a backbone and we make a beer
the way the fuck we want to,
and that was having a backbone is all about you're gonna have the backbone to
make a let beer that looks and tastes like piss a watered down.
Shitty beer comes from the backbone rugged mountains.
Okay.
You know something?
I think whenever you have a pussy product,
you know one of the red flags as he gets Sam Elliot to do the voiceover,
you know,
cause you're like,
oh my God,
people are gonna see right through the fact that,
I mean come on people cores,
it's one of those beers when like you're hung over that you actually drink.
That's like vitamin water for an alcoholic.
They're trying to tie it into the fucking rocky mountains.
I mean,
I know,
I know.
They,
they get their fucking water from the rocky mountain.
Let's go down this country like a backbone.
The tough gash she had.
Give me some of that school band.
Core line.
Yeah.
Jesus.
I'm anyways,
where the fuck am I?
How the fuck that even start talking about that.
The other day I got a call from work,
uh,
the other day I got a call from her.
Okay,
let,
let's,
let's reset this up again.
The case,
24 years old,
he has 17 kids now.
He has four kids.
He's married,
works with public utilities,
does very hard manual labor.
He works his fucking ass off and all his money goes straight to his fucking wife
and his kids.
All right.
The other day I got a call from her at work and she told me to meet her at the
doctor's office because she doesn't like taking the kids to the doctor alone.
When I get there,
she starts yelling at me as usual red flag and they,
and then said,
then she said,
all you know how to do his work,
so why don't you just go back to work and saying all I do is
pick up after you and the kids and basically calling me a loser for working and
making money.
I'm doing my best to provide for my kids.
She takes my money.
She spends my money on stupid shit.
We've been married for a year and four months now,
but you get four kids.
Did you have quadruplets,
sir?
What happened?
I don't know bill.
I just like to hear your take on the situation and give me some advice.
All right.
Oh,
okay.
gauges.
Here we go.
All right.
First things first.
I don't know what you said before.
She said all you know how to do his work,
so why don't you go back to work?
That could have been anything from her actually being a jerk to her saying,
yeah,
Philip has a cold and you said,
which one's Philip?
We've got so many fucking kids.
Which one?
Which one is easy is either the little a rusty heroin,
then she up
hello.
You know how to do his work.
Where did you go back to work?
You know,
if she said it like that,
then what can you do?
Um,
but it doesn't seem,
I don't know.
The fact that she's saying all I do is pick up after you and the kids,
uh,
this,
this is what you need to do.
The worst thing that you can do,
um,
when you want somebody to hear your point is to be a fucking asshole.
Like me.
It's like when I,
when I approached that lady at the bank,
you know,
I,
she didn't hear what I was saying because h she's,
you know,
she's a cunt.
All right?
Who's kidding who?
But beyond that was I was a dick to her.
So no one's gonna listen to you if you're a dick.
So if you really,
if you want to stay with this woman,
right?
You're going through a rough period in your relationship.
What you have to do is you got to walk away from that situation,
you know,
go scream into a pillow.
All the shit that you want to say to her or go yell at your windshield is you
drive around the block 15 fucking times for a couple of drinks.
Whatever you gotta do,
unwind.
And this is how I do it cause I have a brutal temper and just write down on a
piece of paper what you want to fucking convey.
All right?
And then practice it.
I know this sounds crazy to people who don't have this problem,
but that's what I have to do because I,
I'll sit there and like that bank thing,
I,
I tried to practice it.
My first attempt at practicing,
I would start off slow and eventually get pissed all over again.
I'd be like,
hey listen,
I noticed that when you went in,
you know,
you open your car door into my car and then he came out and then you did it
again.
And it's like,
what the fuck?
You know?
Okay wait,
I can't do that.
All right.
Start off a bill.
And each time I would get further and further to the end,
so that's what you have to do with this person.
You have to sit down hour and 12 minutes.
How fucking long is this podcast?
You have to sit down with her and just be like,
look,
I
mean,
I don't know what you're just say,
listen,
we have four kids.
That's a situation you don't have.
The place is going to be a mess and I am working.
Okay.
Obviously I'm not giving you what you need.
What?
What more do you need from me?
Okay,
let her see.
That's it.
Probably a good way.
All right,
we need to talk.
You seem really upset with me.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
What more do you need from me then what I'm doing?
All right.
Since she sees that you're relaxed,
you're going to hear what the hell she wants to say.
Then when she says what she has to say,
you know,
fair enough.
All right,
here's,
here's what I need from you.
All right?
And then in a nice way,
you got to tell her to stop spending all your money on stupid shit,
all right?
That's what you gotta do.
And I'm telling you the key when you're fucking trying to make some headway in
your relationship is with the woman,
is you can't lose your fucking cool,
all right?
And they will,
if,
if you pack them into a corner sometimes when they're doing something wrong,
cause they humans,
they're going to do something wrong.
When you back,
I'm in the corner and they did something wrong.
Watch out.
If they start attacking you all right with shit that has nothing to do what
you're arguing about,
like you're arguing about,
you know,
whatever,
yet you,
you fucking,
um,
she keeps leaving the TV on and going to bed and it's on all night.
She's fucking whatever,
whatever the fuck that debt causes the,
the electric bill to go up.
If all of a sudden she starts going,
well,
you know,
you just mad cause you,
you're just short or she attacks you for that or some other bullshit or just
you're just a fucking ass hole right there.
She just abandoned her argument and what she's doing now,
she's just trying to make you mad so that she can steer the argument into some
other bullshit or just hopefully get you to say something so fucked up that it,
uh,
it just totally camouflage is,
you know,
the bullshit that she did to start the fucking argument basically.
So just keep your cool.
You got to sit down,
you've got to eat,
dude,
you got four girls,
you got four kids with this,
with this girl,
you're attached at the hip with this woman.
Okay?
So what you want to do is try to have a good time.
You're good guy.
You work in your fucking ass off.
Okay.
She needs to appreciate that.
And uh,
she has to appreciate that,
you know,
uh,
what do you want to do?
You want to fucking whatever the fuck you're doing.
He didn't want to walk around picking up a spongebob squarepants stuffed animals
all day.
You know,
you gotta be like,
sweetheart,
you had four fucking kids.
See,
this is why I'm not good at it,
so we don't yet for fucking kids.
The fuck do you think was going to happen?
You know,
get your tubes tied.
Quit bitching at me.
See,
that's the first pass.
That's the first way I would say,
and by you get to the end,
he to say,
listen,
you know I love you.
You love me.
We have four beautiful kids.
We have to work together.
It's definitely a trying time at being this show with all these kids,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
And I'm telling you,
your,
your life will be like,
it'll be better.
It'll be better if you work it out.
But the worst thing you want to do was come and her after you've had a few pops
and said,
listen,
let me tell you something.
You'd dump con all right,
I'm the backbone of this fucking country.
You don't want to come at her that way.
All right,
you stupid bitch.
I'm fucking working my balls off.
Why don't you go out there and that God dip fucking oil rig all day.
You know,
once you get out of the pharmacy,
get on the fucking pill.
Maybe you wouldn't have to be picking up so much shit.
All right,
well let me know to pull out.
You'd say dumb shit like that,
you know,
and then you're gonna have a year and a half fucking horrific relationship.
You don't want to do that.
So that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
And as I mentioned,
I am up on Twitter now and actually enjoying it.
I have made peace with the,
with the tweeting.
You don't,
I feel like right now I feel like a,
uh,
I feel like Johnny Damon when he went to the Yankees after trashing twittering,
but the,
now I'm fucking,
you know,
shaved my beard.
You got a haircut.
Oh,
you know,
I'm just going to credit,
come in and contribute on Twitter wherever I can.
Uh,
no,
it's not that bad.
It's not the best.
Just typical me.
I am,
uh,
I'm an old soul.
I'm a crabby 80 year old as a 42 year old.
I am.
I Look Ah,
shot.
No,
I don't like it.
I didn't like Facebook.
I still don't really like it.
But,
um,
I'm at the mercy of you guys.
You guys all go to Twitter.
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
You know,
I stayed on my space as long as I could.
I felt like I was in a ghost town,
like some old Motortown that dried up and I was just sitting there listening to
the rusty hinges,
you know,
is the doors swing swung back and forth.
Oh,
Jesus belt.
We get it.
Stop being so fucking dramatic.
You're at Twitter in fair.
You're a Twitter.
Um,
yeah,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
You guys all have a,
a,
y'all have a wonderful week and a
fuck yourself.
All right.
See
you.
Everybody needs to
[inaudible]
illuminate main street cinema,
Rio.
We don't care about no government.
45.
Wow.